[ Musique ]
Commentaire :
Dans le cadre de la semaine bleue
le président du Conseil Départemental
Cyrille Melchior, est allé ce mercredi 10
octobre à la rencontre des gramounes
du Cirque de Mafate.
C'est sur le stade près de l'école de Marla,
qu'était organisée une journée
intergénérationnelle dédiée à la
préservation du patrimoine culturel et à
la sensibilisation sur l'éducation,
la prévention, et la santé.
Le département accompagne cette belle
action réalisée ici à Marla dans Mafate
par les deux associations de familles de Mafate
en lien avec l'ORIAPA et la
structure pour bien être chez soi.
Le Département les accompagne tout
simplement parce que nous avons en
charge les personnes âgées notamment
celles et ceux qui sont les plus en difficulté.
Et je tiens à dire que nous
nous inscrivons résolument dans le cadre
d'un plan pour les seniors parce que
vous savez qu'à La Réunion il y a de plus
en plus de gramounes et il s'agit de les
accompagner, d'accompagner leur famille
de façon à ce que ces gramounes
soient bien considérés,
bénéficient de la solidarité départementale.
Commentaire :
Une vingtaine de professionnels étaient présents
sur les stands, proposant des
ateliers allant des gestes de premiers secours,
au diagnostic de vision, en
passant par le bilan d'autonomie
ou encore la prévention de chutes.
L'occasion pour tous les mafatais
d'échanger, de s'informer, et d'exprimer ses attentes.
Cette journée c'est une journée intergénérationnelle
du patrimoine, patrimoine social et culturel
avec donc la venue de tous les mafatais
du Cirque de Mafate.
Après on a aussi de la prévention santé
qui est là avec nous pour sensibiliser
les gramounes, les jeunes aussi tous les
participants, nous avons aussi des ateliers
de théâtre, on a de la musique, ce soir
y'a un groupe de Mafate qui va chanter.
Donc voilà c'est pour mettre en valeur tout
le patrimoine social et culturel de Mafate.
Discours de Cyrille MELCHIOR :
" Quand on voit ici de jeunes enfants
quand on voit ici les parents et les grands parents
et bien c'est ça le lien intergénérationnel
qui fait la force de La Réunion,
qui fait la force de notre bien vivre ensemble,
Et c'est pour ça que le Département accompagne,
et on accompagne en particulier nos gramounes
zot toute, les gramounes parce qu'il faut de la solidarité en faveur des gramounes."
[ Musique ]